this program is brought to you by Emory
University
a new structure of our major that's
coming online next fall and what this is
going to do is it will provide our
students with three different sort of
ways of focusing their studies through
the major path all leading toward The
Bachelor of Arts in music they can
choose to focus on performance which of
course has a heavy dose of ensemble
requirements and also private lesson
requirements that particular track is
open by audition we also have a track
coming online to major in composition
which will allow students who maybe play
an instrument or maybe even don't play
an instrument but who are very
interested in composing music creating
music whether for electronic ensembles
electronic media or in traditional
classical sorts of genres to pursue
their interests in composition with
their final project the capstone project
of the degree would be a composed piece
that would be performed in recital we
also have a third track coming online
which is what we're calling the research
track which is designed to educate
students who are interested in pursuing
careers or pursuing just their passions
their interests in musicology in
ethnomusicology and in music theory so
with this particular path what it's
going to be doing is essentially drawing
in students like those right now who are
majoring in both music and history who
may be interested in combining those
interests in studying the history of
music as their primary their principal
area of focus for their work likewise
students who maybe double majoring in
anthropology and music may be drawn to
combine those two areas and to pursue a
degree in music focusing on
ethnomusicology and this particular
track is designed to give the students
the training that they would need to
enable them to pursue graduate work at
the phd level in ethnomusicology
musicology or music theory and
ultimately to pursue careers as
university professors researchers in
those areas we think that this new
degree structure will only serve to make
our degree more attractive and more
doable for an even broader array of
students than our current
being served in the structure that we
have right now all three of these tracks
we've designed specifically to maintain
this deep commitment that we all have
here to educating the entire student to
multidisciplinary work they're all
designed to to foster and even to
encourage students to explore other
areas of opportunity at Emory for
learning including pursuing double
majors as they may be interested the
preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University